jessica how are you hi john i'm good how
are you
outstanding outstanding how can i help
hi so i am calling because i have
a sibling a brother that basically came
home from college with a mental
breakdown
it's now been five and a half years he's
been living with my parents
and basically um
his making their life hell so um
the rest of the siblings and i have
talked about
possibly in doing like an intervention
because my parents don't know how to set
boundaries with them and just telling
them how we feel about the situation
because we also
feel like we're losing them so i just
thought i'd give you a call and see if
you had any
advice if that's even something we
should do if we should just sit back and
watch this
unfold for the next who knows how long
or if we should tell them how we feel
and maybe
help them with some resources yeah so
tell me when you say mental breakdown
five and a half years ago
was it just a anxiety fit i don't like
taking tests is he schizophrenic like
paint me a picture of that
oh well he basically he was working and
doing school a lot
and didn't sleep and so mentally
couldn't take
all of the pressure um
misbehaved a little bit not terrible but
the school basically released them to
you can go home
we don't need you to finish your
semester um
and then found out through
various different things that he does
have some mental health uh
disorders he has a personality disorder
like borderline
um and his
he does have anxiety and depression on
top of that that's been medicated but
this summer he went to chase this girl
who didn't like him on his medications
and so now we've seen a decline in his
mental health
as well as uh there's a lot of guilt on
my parents part he went through some
medical
trauma earlier in his life and so i
think they feel like they have to
provide him whatever he wants yeah so
here's the thing you're right on you and
your brothers
and sisters are right on um
there comes a point when
our loved ones our brother our sister
sometimes it's our dad
or our mom there comes a moment when
our loved one becomes a grown man who's
making my mom cry
right and yes he's my brother yes i love
him
yes he's got some challenges yes he went
through some nonsense some
some crap as a kid but right now
he's a 25 year old or 26 year old who's
breaking up my parents marriage
who is keeping my dad from sleeping a a
full night of sleep
who is playing my mom like an accordion
and making my mom
his hair turned gray making her cry and
there is a moment as a parent
um do you have kids of your own yes okay
so you know
i'm just talking to you parent to parent
here there's moments when we get so far
down our own rabbit hole trying to care
for
our kids that we lose the forest from
the trees right and
what a i like your word what an
intervention can do for your parents is
let them know that
they're not alone you and your brothers
and sisters can pull them out of
whatever river they're drowning in help
dry them off
and then offer them some resources but
probably the most important resource
you're going to offer them
is that you've got their back
right that you love them you support
them you're going to teach them how to
draw boundaries you're going to support
whatever boundaries they draw
and that might have ugly consequences
for your brother for a season
right and people with borderline
personality disorder
they're they are brilliant and lovely
and hilarious
and hellacious to work with because
you are the greatest person who has ever
lived until you are the worst person who
has ever lived right
exactly mom and dad are the most
wonderful people until they have ruined
my life and you guys suck and i
hate you and i'm just going to quit
digging my meds and go off because she
loves me more
and this girl is going to be the
greatest girl who ever lived until she's
not
right and that's such as the up and
downs of folks
who are on borderline personality
disorder and don't work really really
hard
to come to terms with these
rollercoaster fireball emotions that
rage through their bodies
and so yes at the end of the day you
need to get your parents out of a
burning house
and they need to hear love and support
from you and from your
siblings my my recommendation for that
would be to let them know hey
we're going to set up a time that we all
want to meet whether that's in person or
because of the
the the current medical climate we're
going to do a
zoom meeting and somebody needs to that
they trust
there's always that one sibling that
kind of takes the lead it might be you
that they said hey call the knucklehead
on the radio and see what he has
to say but whoever the the brother or
sister is that that has their trust the
most
um can call in and say listen um we love
you and
you gotta start drawing some boundaries
because we're worried about you
and mom we're worried about you and dad
and we love you
and we don't want to see our brother
hurting y'all anymore
absolutely absolutely how does that how
does that hit you
uh it's just validation i think because
we
i mean we've been watching this unfold
for the last five years so we're very
um we feel like we've lost something too
with our parents that they've they're so
focused on him
and unable to see how it's hurting
everyone else so
well here's the thing beware of this
after five and a half years
caring for their hurting son has become
an identity for your parents
they have found meaning in their hurt
and they have found meaning in their
pain
for parents who like you said he had
medical trauma as a kid he probably
experienced some hard things as a kid
sometimes this lashing that parents
subject themselves to especially with
their adult
kids when they won't draw boundaries
there's some
weird ugly tiny demon in the back of
their hearts and minds to say you
deserve this
this is because of and so expect some
resistance
expect some yeah but somebody need like
expect that
and just know going in all all four of
you is there four there's four of you
right
that y'all go in as a united front that
says mom and dad this is enough
this is enough and we're gonna help you
draw boundaries so whatever resources
y'all can come up with
either locally for him
really the boundaries for for a 25 year
old are going to be
you've got three months and then you're
out and then some you all need to rotate
going to visit mom and dad or calling
mom and dad and letting them know that
when they get this torrent of
um this torrent of borderline response
which is going to be your
you're going to make me homeless you're
the worst you're throwing me out on my
ear you don't care about me you don't
love me all that stuff
partridge into pear tree that your
parents are constantly being filled up
you're holding their arms up in the
desert as they are desperate for water
and you're helping them out get through
this season and then they've got to kick
him out
they got to change the locks on the
house if it gets to that probably he'll
throw a temper tantrum and take off
and then they're going to have to hold
boundaries and the boundaries might be
when you get a job
we'll help you out if you need support
buying your medication if you can show
us that you're on your medication we'll
help you out whatever that's going to
look like but
i trust you and your brothers and
sisters do that but yeah 100 you've got
my blessing you'll need to step
in help your mom and dad out of the out
of the river
they're drowning they've made an
identity out of treading water and it's
time for folks who love them to step in
and help what a great call thank you so
much
um jessica you're a saint and you and
your brothers and sisters are awesome
i'd love to know how that conversation
goes so please call me back
let me know how the intervention goes
how your parents take it if they take it
well if they don't take it well i'd love
to hear how they are doing